let's jump to the story from the Daily
Mail refund the police Portland finally
launches Crackdown on crime after
defunding the police by 15 million
dollars as it hires more District
Attorneys and investigators to tackle
spiraling car and retail theft all right
how long until you you think it is until
liberals starts saying we were always in
support of the police it's the
conservatives that hated police
whether they want to refund the police I
hope they kept the receipt because I
think a lot of those cops ain't coming
back you drive them out of their jobs
you make it as difficult as possible for
them to do it this was their plan the
whole time yep they got all the
conservative leaning cops to quit and
now that none of them would touch the
Department's a 10-foot pole they're
going to hire only the people who
support their crackpot ideas between
that and covid you know between the
vaccine mandates and all the other
things that drove that you know changed
the force out of this Kim Fox in Chicago
big prosecutor wouldn't prosecute Jesse
Smollett was a Soros funded D.A which I
know you're not supposed to say but that
is just a fact
she's not running for reelection I I
think we're going to see a shift here
and part of the shift I would imagine is
because they got to get this shift going
before 2024 because this is a winning
issue for the Republicans yes but the
cops are going to be pro-anti for now
we've already seen it happen and there's
a video of a guy backing away from
antifa and they're threatening him with
weapons and the cops grab the victim and
arrest him wow maybe maybe I don't know
the full context yeah but it's a guy
backing up saying get away from me get
away from me and then the cop apologizes
to an antifa woman so I'm sorry ma'am
what it gotta be man because if if they
if they're bringing these police
officers back in these blue areas these
cops are risking their their livelihoods
by just doing their jobs they get
charged for arresting the wrong person
by one of these liberal DA's until they
get dragged through the media they're
going to get charged they're going to be
convicted they're going to get thrown in
jail so they got to be on the same time
what happens when Portland says all
right we're going to be hiring 500 new
cops and all the applicants are antifa
I'm not kidding they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna be the ones to show
up and be like yes I'll be a cop and
then basically a far left extremist gang
puts on the badge and can go around
doing whatever they want with government
sanction
that's that's it it's definitely
possible part of me hopes that their
ideology their ideology would select
against it I understand that they don't
have principles but they hate cops so
much but you think that would get them
pushed out of their Social Circles nope
they'd be like they'll have a direct
action meeting and they'll say we're
going to take over the department we're
gonna we're gonna take that those badges
and then we'll control they're gonna go
yay just like when the BLM activists
cheered for the police arresting the guy
from his own home they say the police
are bad and then they go yeah and call
the cops and cheer for them when the
cops show up Yep they're posting on
Twitter arrest them arrest them arrest
these people
they want they want that power I thought
you were about to say that wait wait
what happens when they're all trans I
thought that was where we were going
with it but I mean but a lot of them
would be right that's that's the thing
about the ideology yeah no have you seen
there was a I think James Lindsay posted
this they're already wearing rainbow
armbands oh man and I'm like this is
really weird everything's changing yeah
or you know kind it's changing but in
many ways staying the same it's like
it's like history rhyming it's not a red
armband it's a rainbow armband but it
basically represents the same kind of
authoritarian pressures they just got
all the the colors covered
that's right the rainbow yeah so they're
all all the entire spectrum of
authoritarianism yeah in one armband yep
yep it exists on a spectrum Tim I mean
it does but yeah I guess the issue was
uh
Portland's been collapsing I think uh
what is it they had like a famous
restaurant shut down because the crime
is so bad there's a bunch of cafes are
shutting down
I don't know what they thought was gonna
happen or would any of these studies
thought was going to happen and so for
me I'm kind of like good I don't care
yeah but it's the problem is the
aftermath yeah when they start hiring
far left extremists we're seeing the
story of the mass Exodus from California
and we're like aha look at that you know
moderate and right-leaning people are
fleeing and going to Florida and Texas
and it's like yeah you know what that
means right most many of them are
probably cops many of them worked in
government law or like law enforcement
things like that now the left is going
to open up those positions and make
appointments of far left extremists into
those seats of government California may
lose a lot of people but now they're
going to create a lot of far left
extremists in positions of authority and
power yeah yeah the good ones I mean I'm
in Texas myself and uh you know it's a
big story right now obviously of people
coming it's like you're right the good
ones are coming right the ones who are
uh who are open to coming to Texas open
to come into Tennessee or wherever uh
then you get left with even even Bluer
in some cases obviously it's going to
make Texas a little bit more purple than
it was I mean I'm in Dallas so it's
already be pretty pretty 50 50 red blue
but yeah what's the effect to be in in
the LA and San Francisco which is
already just struggling beyond belief we
barely get coverage of it there's this
crazy video I saw today where a guy it's
a homeless guy in San Diego who's got a
tent and he's got a knife it looks like
some kind of like buck knife and he's
screaming how he's going to kill a woman
or some random woman and then he just
stabs the wall as hard as he can it's
kind of nothing happens but he's
screaming the dude filming is like every
day he does this he threats he's going
to kill somebody and like the cops won't
do anything oh my God why would they
what are they gonna do about it what are
they going to do shop and arrest the guy
and then they just open the door and let
him go again it's it's a cultural and
social Decay yeah that's it I wonder I
got to be honest what's causing all of
the mental issues that surround
homelessness
not every homeless person is mentally
ill no some of them are vagabonds by
choice but a lot of these people who see
sleeping on the city streets there's
something wrong upstairs what's causing
this Spike you know what I mean yeah
it's not a combination of mental health
issues and also drug policy yeah it's
that also I mean look man is not living
the way he is meant to live in this
society and that produces negative
outcomes physically and mentally
yeah I agree with that I saw your Tweet
today about about you know kids what's
causing people that are young people to
yeah I tweeted not want to be who they
are I mean that that's this is a huge
problem well I was just thinking about
it in a general sense I tweeted we need
to start asking ourselves why young
people are so desperate to be someone
else instead of themselves and it's
gotten like in 9 000 retweets or
whatever the funny thing though is the
left responses
immediately talking about trans issues
right I found that and I was just like
I'm just I was speaking generally kids
wanting to be a famous YouTuber like
wanting to be Mr Beast or whatever
my point is this some people have lashed
on that and been like every child looks
up to somebody and wants to do that look
I am outright saying why are there
people who are dying their skin why are
there people who who are trans why are
there people who are trans species why
are there people who create fake
personas why are the people who use
different names why why don't they just
want to develop who they are and someone
responded to me a conservative person
was like
it's normal for kids to want to be
someone else and then I'm just like is
that a projection because when I was a
kid I didn't want to be anybody else
that didn't exist in my mind I was just
I just was what I was there's a viral
video from a show called the good doctor
where it's about it's a show about an
autistic doctor I've never seen it and
the patient is a transgender little boy
who has testicular cancer and you find
that at the end of the scene but he says
something like he says he's autistic so
he's like you're a boy because you have
X Y chromosomes not xx and then the kid
says how did you know you were supposed
to be a boy other than uh with uh you
know other than biology and he goes
That's you're quite your question makes
no sense I'm not supposed to be anything
I am a boy and I was like
that's a perfect line you're not
supposed to be anything you're supposed
to be who you are what you are why are
people so desperate young people so
desperate to not be themselves I mean a
lot of them a lot of the mechanisms that
we have for
self-discovery and for emotional
development and Social Development have
gone by the wayside you know we don't go
outside and play anymore as kids we
don't really interact everything that we
do is on and apps through social media
we're filtered through these programs
that have algorithms that shape our
world and they're programmed to re to
reward you and give you a dopamine hit
based on certain triggers yeah so our
entire Society has shifted from
something that allows you to be able to
grow and have that self-discovery
process and figure out who you are and
reward you for being an individual and
just being yourself to making you want
and again these children are
impressionable your brain doesn't fully
form and develop until you're 25. so we
have these uh this this this group of
millions of kids who don't go through
this process in their entire life
experiences geared toward wanting to to
please an algorithm which is essentially
making you want to be what you see on
the screen instead of figuring out who
the hell you are absolutely getting
plastic surgery to look like Snapchat
filters young young women are developing
fake Tourette's Syndrome yeah because
they want to emulate what they see on
these apps and yet social contagion with
respect to transgenderism is completely
dismissed there are kids who are
literally pretending to have Tourette's
there has not been some massive uptick
in tourettes and yet when we see a
massive uptick in gender confusion that
couldn't possibly be social contagious
we were always that way we say society
allows them to say it but it may not be
pretending they may act no social
contagion doesn't mean pretending yeah
right they're planning to be Tourette's
some of these young women are actually
developing a social
issue and they're getting Tourette's
Syndrome from watching prominent
Tourette's personalities are coming from
with inside the home too we talk a lot
about fatherless homes but yeah um you
know there's a piece that I wrote for
timcastnews.com it's actually just
there was a a study from 1994 that just
resurfaced that found that 53 of mothers
of boys who identify as trans have their
own psychological issues including
depression and Borderline Personality
Disorder so there's it's not even just
uh social contagion I think is a large
part of it but some of this is being
directed from within these these
children's own homes because their
parents have their own issues that they
haven't sorted and that's even before
social media right 1994. I mean I I
agree with you I think social media has
a huge factor and not just because of
the incentives of it but because you go
from maybe you grew up wanting to be
famous or you wanted to be you know
successful but now you want to be
special and you're doing it in a way
that is performative it's it's public in
in a way that never existed before I
mean I I you know whether it's the media
whether it's kids growing up the the
incentives of of getting feedback from
friends from Family from fans in the in
the moment it's very hard to I can't
even imagine growing up in a society
where you are living in public and and
you have in your mind the potential of
is this the thing that's going to make
me famous or special and and you're
doing it on Instagram you're doing all
these platforms that that have that
ability and then you're also doing it
with all these the the normal pressures
that you have with being a kid and being
at school and dealing with things and
then and even with when it comes to to
bullying and the again the normal things
that you would just go through in
elementary school in junior high and
high school there's not an off switch
anymore because of these platforms you
go home you're still dealing with it
online through DMs yeah other people
tweeting and tick-tocking and sharing
your post it never goes away so we have
a entire culture that's sick right now
and again when we talk about things like
school shootings this is part of the
reason we've created a culture that is
completely completely ill and and needs
a little little bit of reformation we've
taken God out of people's lives we've
taken the meaning out of people's lives
by devaluing the family structure and
what role families should play in our
lives and all of it has an impact and
it's all planned out in these really
weird ways as we sit here and scratch
our heads trying to figure out what's
going on because we're too afraid not us
but in general people are afraid to
address the real issues yeah yeah well I
think another massive problem is just
how much we have forgotten what nature
is in and of itself so wealth allows you
to insulate yourself from nature and
it's also allowed us to insulate
ourselves from our own nature we think
of it as something external that's
nature it's out there but you're a human
being you also have a nature to you and
so not only do we not know how to combat
the threats that exist in the outside
world we've insulated ourselves from we
have actually forgotten how to combat
the elements of our own nature that are
nefarious you know I'm reminded of that
scene in the movie Snatch you guys ever
see that one with um Brad Pitt uh Brad
Pitt's in it uh who else is in it Jason
Statham's in it there's a lot of people
that are in it and there's that scene
where Jason Statham Statham is with his
buddy and then his buddy says like you
can't drink milk because it's out of
sync with Evolution and he's like what
do you mean and he's like humans didn't
evolve to drink milk they doubted it
later so it's not properly attuned to
like our bodies and digestion you
shouldn't drink it and I'm thinking
about that as it pertains to Modern
social media humans this technology is
out of sync with Evolution humans
survived by being certain ways like
Community Family things like that we
certainly want to do away with bad
things and and keep hold on to the good
things and the good ideas but now we
have this machine that is feeding us a
feedback loop of dopamine hits and other
psychotic garbage and it's making young
people literally go insane yeah and I
have to say I think you know it's been a
problem longer than this but covid made
it worse I I think that the the after
effects of covet I've got this this
Theory this column I'm thinking about
which is that basically covet explains
everything over the last couple years I
think you know whether it's January 6th
or anything I think I think that there's
so much of of what is the is the after
effect of those insane year and a half
two years I mean in some people's cases
people that I know it it remains to this
day that it will have permanent damage
on on our culture that in ways that I
don't think we even fully comprehend
that that in disrupting the nature of
what we were supposed to be doing of
what we're supposed to of how we're
supposed to live and yet we all went
along with this for you know some people
longer than others I I think the
disintegration of the family may be the
the like the worst apocalyptic scenario
people don't realize
what we we talk about oh zombies meteor
strikes world war three it's like dude
families breaking up could be worse than
all of those things no it is because the
family is the most foundational building
block of any social structure it's all
built Atop The Family if I I I I feel
like because there's no communal family
structure you end up with rapid crime my
neighbor doesn't know me doesn't care
about me I am meaningless to their
existence so why not exploit that you
end up with crime going crazy in these
cities
yeah exactly well part of the beauty of
family and part of the beauty again of
what is built into us what is built into
our own nature is the people closest to
us are people we are literally
biologically hardwired to want to fight
for and protect in a way that we are not
strangers you can have a very
good-hearted police officer who
genuinely cares about you and who's even
well trained he is not going to have the
same internal motivations to fight for
you the way that your brother or your
father will and what we've attempted to
do because we've forgotten our nature is
try to universalize the protection of
one another well we'll just build a
great big system that does it and we
won't have to rely on these connections
it doesn't work I'm not saying that
having a legal system doesn't work that
having police departments doesn't work
but what I am saying is the thing that
works the best is the family in the
family unit and we've tried to Outsource
so much of what it does best that we're
just failing at all of those things and
now people don't even end up you know
having families anymore close
connections to them because they believe
they can rely on these institutions
instead and they don't end up getting
the same results thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time